Alabama Senate candidate Roy Moore
remained defiant after new allegations
of unwelcome advances towards women and
teenaged girls a woman tells The
Washington Post that Moore called her
out of a high school math class 40 years
ago to ask her on a date another woman
tells al.com that Roy Moore grabbed her
rear in back in 1991 after he was
married the former judge is trying to
discredit an accuser who came forward on
Monday his lawyer says it more signature
in her high school yearbook maybe a fake
the candidate is under growing pressure
from Washington to step aside but right
now President Trump is not getting
publicly involved Dean Reynolds is in
Birmingham Alabama with the latest Dean
good morning good morning well Alabama's
other Republican Senator Richard Shelby
is not supporting judge Moore and now
says he will write someone else's name
onto the ballot next month Mitch
McConnell the Senate Majority Leader is
not ruling out the possibility of
expelling Moore if he wins the election
- which Moore tweeted dear Mitch
McConnell bring it on
when the allegations are made and it's
not true it's also horrible for the
person who those allegations are
directed against Roy Moore's team tried
to paint the embattled Republican Senate
candidate as the victim yesterday while
aiming to discredit at least one of the
women accusing him of inappropriate
behavior when he was an adult and they
were teenagers attorney Phillip Jarecki
said the only piece of evidence provided
by Beverley young Nelson a signed
yearbook from Moore might be forged we
demand that you immediately release the
yearbook we accept that challenge if
there is a hearing that is conducted by
the Senate to allow an independent
expert to examine the signature in the
yearbook and new accusations surfaced
yesterday with one woman claiming that
in 1991 Moore who was married roped her
and asked about the looks of her young
daughters another accuser says in 1977
while in high school she was summoned
from class to the principal's office for
a phone call it was from Moore
who asked her on a date she eventually
went out with more who she says gave her
a forceful unwanted kiss late Wednesday
evening mores campaign put out a letter
aiming to affirm his character with
comments from 12 different women who
have known the judge for many years do
you believe his accusers president Trump
ignored reporters questions about why
more yesterday at the White House but
the president's daughter and White House
adviser Ivanka Trump said she has no
reason to doubt mores accusers one of
whom says she was 14 when he tried to
seduce her Ivanka Trump went on to say
there is a special place in hell for
people who prey on children Gale alright
Dean many people feel that way thank you
very much